- So, wait, there's another
blockbuster coming soon.
Fast and Furious.
- [Michelle] Oh yeah.
(audience cheering)
Aww.
- Is there anything
you can say about it?
- You know, I just watched it
and I gotta say, you know,
it's almost nostalgic
because we're coming to the
end of like a 23 year journey.
- Gosh.
- And
I gotta say, after watching it, I'm like,
I still don't understand
how we're able to surpass
the last one that we did.
'Cause like, after going to
space, I was literally like,
"what could we possibly do to top this?"
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I just don't understand.
- Do you think y'all did
with this one?
- I really do.
- Yeah.
And the beauty of it is,
in a sense,
you're gonna be left
like a little incomplete,
after the movie's over.
You're gonna be like,
"Wait a minute."
- What?
- "You can't, no, no, no, no, no,
movies don't end like this."
(Michelle laughs)
That's all I can say.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's
the greatest teaser ever.
What?